In the early 1990s, director James Cameron
convinced Carolco Pictures — which produced
movies such as Terminator 2, Total Recall,
and Rambo — to option the film rights to
Spider-Man. But Cameron's production was ultimately
tangled in an inescapable web. Why couldn't
one of Hollywood's most powerful directors
get this film made?
"Oh no, no, ah!"
Too edgy
Cameron's plans for Spider-Man have become
a Hollywood legend. According to Rebecca Keegan's
book The Futurist: The Life and Films of James
Cameron, Spidey creator Stan Lee absolutely
loved Cameron's treatment. Ultimately, many
of Cameron's own ideas—like Spidey's organic
web-shooters and Uncle Ben's carjacking death—made
it into the Sam Raimi-directed Spider-Man
movie from 2002.
But for every one of Cameron's good ideas,
there were at least three that were...not.
Cameron called for Peter to curse like a sailor,
which would've resulted in an R-rating. And
then there was a scene where Peter peeped
in Mary Jane's window as she dressed, and
one where Spidey and MJ get...intimate on
the Brooklyn Bridge while Peter describes
the creepy ways spiders mate.
Uh, what?
"Aaaahhh!"
Low budget
Cameron would've likely made Spider-Man right
after Terminator 2, which had a $100 million
budget. According to Janet Wasko's How Hollywood
Works, Carolco only committed to a $50 million
budget, a huge step backwards for him. And
if the reported budgets of his next two films
- $100 million for True Lies and a record-setting
$200 million for Titanic - tell us anything,
it's that Spidey's balance sheet wasn't going
to fly.
Bad casting
Rumor has it that Cameron wanted to cast Arnold
Schwarzenegger as Doctor Octopus. Schwarzenegger
even hinted at his involvement in an interview
with Empire, only going so far as to vaguely
say the the studio "went in another direction."
There are yet more rumors and reports of Cameron's
dream cast for the film...and one of them
is a pretty strange choice. Edward Furlong,
whose big break came as John Connor in Cameron's
Terminator 2, was reportedly the director's
pick for Peter Parker, and Leonardo DiCaprio
was to play Harry Osborne. Of course, Leo
wouldn't play second fiddle to just anyone.
Johnny Depp? Sure. Eddie Furlong? Not a chance.
The report also pegs Drew Barrymore as Gwen
Stacey and J. Jonah Jameson would've been
played by R. Lee Ermey—the drill sergeant
in Full Metal Jacket.
"You will not laugh! You will not cry! You
will learn by the numbers! I will teach you!"
That would have been perfect, but it wouldn't
have been enough to make up for tanking the
principal cast.
Litigation
While the script, casting, and budget issues
all could've become later stumbling blocks,
what ultimately squashed Cameron's Spider-Man
were legal issues. Cameron told Collider that
when Carolco collapsed a few years after they
acquired the rights to Spider-Man, he already
had Titanic in his sights. Moreover, he no
longer wanted to pursue Spider-Man because
of all the competing interests for the rights
amid Carolco's bankruptcy...and Marvel's.
Apparently a number of former writers and
producers all claimed to have had a hand in
developing the project, and they all came
calling.
Marvel's own 1996 bankruptcy process scattered
multiple holding deals to the wind. According
to How Hollywood Works, after Marvel recovered
from bankruptcy, they basically paid off everyone
who was trying to sue for the rights to Spider-Man,
which freed them up to sell the rights to
Sony.
Meanwhile, Cameron turned one of the greatest
human tragedies of all time into a billion-dollar
smash, so he did just fine.
"I'm the king of the world! Woooo! Woo! Woo!"
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know who should've starred in James Cameron's
Spider-Man movie...